the Bulge is a gay bar
ah the knights I've wasted there
104.1 Leslie you're dehydrated I'm
admitting you if I was sick could I do
this
what are you doing cartwheels
and we're not doing them no Tammy
Tammy Ronnie what's going on Welcome to
the Battle Royale right here right now
operation soaring Falcon is in its final
stages
it's time to settle this
ah
an old-fashioned Prairie drink off
jug it smells like
the Swanson family Mash liquor
made from the finest corn ever grown on
American soil it's only legal use is to
strip varnish off of speed boats if you
win he's all yours and if I win I bring
him back to the farm for good
wait what that wasn't the deal Port I'm
thirsty poor me one two then let me in
here I'm gonna
join you and if I win Ron stays here
with us Leslie no don't drink that we
use it to burn warts off of the mules
difficult
poison
oh I made a mistake
I made a mistake
had enough of this watered down baby
formula
not even close not even close
Marvin clones
Glenn Close
Leslie you don't have to do this go to
bed Jimmy
I can't feel my face
my face is numb
councilman Jam changed his vote he's
vote no on front of the Sun what
just said that he changed his mind
then he told me some veneers could
really make my smile pop thoughts oh my
God the vote is in an hour okay we need
to have an emergency strategy session
now what about the firm the perm must
wait autumn
must wait the bill is dead the purposes
are doomed and democracy is over oh my
God I can't believe I decided to get a
perm and should have never let me do
this look Jam saw you on Pawnee today he
knows how much you want this he's just
trying to get something in return this
is a bargaining tool you know this is
why people hate the government because
just when we're about to do something
really good it all falls apart due to
some stupid selfish jerkbust you know
you don't Jam screw Jam I'm just gonna
try to get councilman Milton's vote
Milton he's like 150 years old yeah he's
got grandkids okay and and kids love to
swim and he'll give us his vote he's an
old person and I'll talk to him really
slowly you won't even know what he's
doing I just need to hurry up how do I
look
I don't know how to answer that
all right let's hunker down it's gonna
be a long night
too close to call a real nail biter
anybody's game these are three phrases
you won't hear tonight as Leslie Knope
has been voted out of office but was
expected to be a close race
a not close race horny voters have
decisively removed Leslie Knope from the
city council
Pizza time it's a pizza time sorry
everyone is miserable and you are only
making it worse
thank you
Leslie
I'm here
we have to go hire a new PR director for
the health department
I've never been this hungover I feel
great I ran 5K this morning
no I threw up in the shower
some encouragement
your sweaters on inside out
and backwards
it's been a tough morning
lots of regret and shame should be the
official slogan for snake juice
uh well uh this committee would like to
ask if you are the kind of candidate who
could forgive someone
after they behaved like a complete
jackass this candidate could
especially because this candidate also
paved like a total jackass please don't
worry about it the committee totally
understands
also I can talk about my qualifications
for this position but first I am going
to go throw up in a wastebasket
would you mind if I joined you not at
all
shall we so um Andy
jumped over this fence he was crossing
through to get home and then he fell
right there oh my God
how do we let this happen
dream with me for a second Anne doesn't
this neighborhood deserve a first class
Park imagine a shiny new playground with
jungle gym and swings School tennis
courts volleyball courts racquetball
courts basketball court regulation
football field we could put an
Amphitheater over there with Shakespeare
in the park it's really not that big of
a pit you could do some of those things
it's gonna take a little extra work
but why not try
I think that would be great me too
I'm going in
why don't worry I have a hard hat on I
can see that but yeah April document
this key to any fact-finding mission is
to get right into the Battle Zone you
know it's like George Bush when he flew
over New Orleans or Richard Nixon when
he went to China to see what the Chinese
were up to no oh oh oh oh oh oh
Leslie are you okay
Leslie hold on April's gonna get some
photos for the website can you just be
still don't move around as much
ta-da that looks great yeah will you be
wearing it out of the store today madam
[Music]
hey while I have you can I ask you a
question shoot what if he asked me if
I've been married have you no
well then say that but then he'll wonder
why I haven't been married you know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna say that I was
married the real question is should I
say that I have kids guys like girls
that have kids right whoa what if I get
drunk and I talk about Darfur too much
or not enough what if I don't bring up
Darfur enough Leslie relax
I just have a few more questions for you
Anne what if he shows up with another
woman what if one of my sleeves catches
on fire and it spreads rapidly What If
instead of tic tacs I accidentally pop a
couple of Ambien and I have to keep
punching my leg to stay awake those are
all insane hypotheticals and I promise
you they won't happen
they have happened
all of these have happened to me
uh no there's more one time I
accidentally drank an entire bottle of
vinegar I thought it was terrible wine
once I went out with a guy who wore 3D
glasses the entire evening oh one time I
rode in the sidecar on a guy's
motorcycle and the side card attached
and went down to fly the stairs another
time I went to a really boring movie
with a guy and while I was asleep he
tried to pull out one of my teeth
I literally woke up with his hand in my
mouth
we went out a couple times after that
but then it got weird guys
it's been neck and neck too close to
calm all night but now we're ready to
make a call in the race for city council
Bobby Newport Zion Sweden's candy Empire
and amateur go-kart Champion has won the
race
why are you laughing because my dream is
dead
okay
here's the situation
on a week's vacation they left the keys
to the brand new Porsche
name mine well of course not I'll just
take it for a little Spin and maybe show
it off to a couple of friends I'll just
cruise around the neighborhood well
maybe
maybe yeah of course I should pay
attention here's the thick of the plot
pulled up to the corner at the end of my
block that's when I saw this beautiful
girly girl walking I picked up my car
phone a perpetrate like I was talking
sunroof is open the music was high in
that girl's hand was steadily moving up
my thigh she had opened up three buttons
on her shirt so far I guess that's why I
didn't notice that police car I can't
believe it I made a mistake my parents
are the same no matter time nor place so
to all you kids all across the land no
need to argue parents just don't
understand
all right
thank you thank you
just a little something I know
so what's up uh someone is on fire in
ramsit park they need you to get down
there right away oh my gosh